by the time she touched down
tensions were ratcheting up an american
this senior on this soil is provocative
tonight china has launched a joint
military operation around the island
including firing long-range ammunition
and testing guided weapons it is a
display of military might as well as
anger made height the u.s and taiwan
have colluded to make provocations first
and china has only been compelled to act
out of self-defense in the face of the
us's unscrupulous behavior in defiance
of china's repeated and serious
complaints any countermeasures china is
taking will be justified and necessary
arriving to applause in the capital
taipei nancy pelosi said our
congressional delegation's visit to
taiwan honors america's unwavering
commitment to supporting taiwan's
vibrant democracy america's solidarity
with the 23 million people of taiwan is
more important today than ever as the
world faces a choice between autocracy
and democracy the united states
continues to oppose unilateral efforts
to change the status quo it's pretty
hard to get her to back down once
something becomes a public dispute and
certainly by the time this became a
topic as to whether she should go or not
it was already too late knowing the
speaker
to persuade her otherwise and it
probably wasn't in our interest at that
point to let china talk us out of it
even if maybe it would have been better
that she not go at all in the first
place the self-governing island is
surrounded by south korea and japan to
the north and the philippines to the
south but china is its closest neighbour
just 112 miles away
later this week in six areas surrounding
taiwan the chinese military is expected
to carry out further exercises including
live fire drills
nancy pelosi's trip may be creating a
buzz but it is not unprecedented speaker
newt gingrich visited 25 years ago but
back then china was not the economic and
military superpower it is today the only
u.s president to set foot in taiwan was
dwight eisenhower in 1960
this trip is largely popular with
members of congress but in the 3d chess
of international diplomacy the privately
voiced reticence in the white house and
pentagon may be linked to concerns about
a different part of the world ukraine so
far the chinese have not provided any
significant military support to vladimir
putin such as their world-class drones
but some here worry this visit may mean
that could change
tomorrow speaker pelosi is expected to
visit taiwan's parliament meet the
president and host a lunch this
controversial trip is just getting
started joe pike sky news washington